Donald Trump is already in the
presidential record books he has set the
record for how quickly after being
inaugurated he got more than 50% of the
country to disapprove of the job that
he's doing these numbers are stunning
from the Gallup survey they've measured
presidential approval for decades Donald
Trump hit 51 percent disapproval on
Saturday over the weekend
eight days after being inaugurated and
we have the trendline to show you
popping up over the 50 percent
disapproval mark on Saturday check out
how that stacks up versus past
presidents here is how long it took past
presidents to achieve 50% disapproval
this graphic is just insane seven
hundred and two hundred twenty seven
days for Ronald Reagan thirteen hundred
thirty six days for Bush one to get to
fifty percent disapproval five hundred
seventy three days for Bill Clinton
twelve oh five for Bush two nine hundred
and thirty six days and the President
Obama got to fifty percent disapproval
and eight not eight hundred not eighty
eight days until Donald Trump was at
fifty percent disapproval talk about
fake polling blah blah blah we don't
trust Gallup this is apples to apples
this has been done by the same
organization for a long time dating back
to Ronald Reagan for Bush too it stayed
there for most of the presidency it was
really uh quite a disturbing thing and
this is logical because it's been minor
PR victories hidden in totally
plutocratic executive orders that are
not going to help the average person and
I don't know whether Trump cares about
approval ratings on the one hand he says
he's going to do what he wants to do on
the other hand we know he's so
thin-skinned that maybe he does care but
he'll just write it all off his fake
news I don't know I think he does care
but he's going to try to play it off
like he doesn't I mean I think going
into his presidency the the poll numbers
were kind of artificially high because a
lot of people thought well I'm gonna
give him a chance
oh yeah but you know several days later
he started talking about inaugural crowd
size and started proposing the wall and
the Muslim ban and people are not going
to get behind that yeah the approval
hasn't moved much from inauguration but
the disapproval has absolutely gone up
people
saying yeah I just don't approve of what
he's doing and many Republicans are also
jumping on the bandwagon John McCain
Lindsey Graham but even other
Republicans vocally speaking out against
the immigration ban so a new record set
by Donald Trump in the history books
next let's see if a libertarian minded a
former vice presidential nominee likes
what Donald Trump is doing Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed comm
slash TDP s I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing